you're the number one high school
basketball recruit every school wants
you
where are you going man that's tough
because I I love having this
conversation with people because like
sometimes you're like do you want to go
to a legendary school you're like now I
play at UNC Jordan played here you know
worthy played here but also there's
something about like I'm going to UW I'm
gonna put [__] Washington on the map
they've never had anything like I take
all these things into consideration of
like where you are I've been to uh World
Series games I've been to finals games
I've been to the Masters I've been to so
many amazing things there is nothing
better that we ever went to in my life
than Cameron Indoor Duke versus North
Carolina seeing that environment if I
could play for Coach K that would be one
but also I gotta be honest being like
the number one guy at Kentucky would be
nuts because do you want to play at a
school Jordan play that because you're
always going to be it's always Jordan
and worthy played there yeah yeah so you
have to do so much to come close to that
right